I think it's important not to paint too
broad a brush when you talk about
jihadist or a fundamentalist you're not
talking about a Muslim there are and I
think Muslims are being vocal about
distinguishing themselves between
distinguishing themselves from
fundamentalist and from fundamentalist
interpretations of the of the text so I
just think it's quite dangerous to get
into too facile an analysis about what
an entire you know an entire part of the
world thinks and believes and hopes for
and and in fact what we're what we're
seeing is the influence of a relatively
small number of extremists who are able
to capitalize on as I mentioned earlier
a tremendous sense of disillusionment
and rage and frustration at a lack of
opportunity and that's what's happening
here is that people are capitalizing on
you know a desperate economic situation
and of course a war on terror which is
as I know from having just produced a
film recently with 14 human rights
groups worldwide that featured the
stories of Binyam Mohammed who's an
Ethiopian national British citizen
currently held in Guantanamo Bay
tortured into confessing to crimes he
did not commit and and Khaled el-masri
who was Lebanese national German citizen
pulled off a bus in the middle of
Macedonia and held without charge you
know not a shred of evidence against him
either so when you start to get into a
situation where people are whisked away
in the middle of the night held
incommunicado have the rights abrogated
and are tortured in to humiliate and
humiliated into doing things in say
things that are that are virtually
untrue you are of course going to create
a backlash and a response and I think
that's you know that's where the
fundamentalist energy is coming from